je vais vous parler de gentillesse et
puis je vous dis vous parlez de
conneries j'essaierai de parler de plus
de gentillesse de conneries d'ailleurs
mais je vais vous présenter les choses
en vous disant que la gentillesse est un
vrai pouvoir
et quand on est gentil on n'est pas
forcément con et malgré ça c'est vrai
qu'on constate tout ce qu'on me met dans
un monde de méchant on vit tous dans un
monde de méchants et les les médias nous
nous donne des images tous les jours à
manger comme quoi effectivement on est
méchant on a des expressions qu'on
entend tout le temps on n'est pas dans
le monde des bisounours c'est bien connu
ou encore le temps c'est de l'argent ou
bien encore on n'est pas là pour faire
du social
ce genre de choses qu'on imagine qu'on
entend effectivement tous les jours que
ce soit dans nos métiers ou ailleurs et
pour ma part je pense que c'est vrai on
est malheureusement dans un monde de
méchants et et j'ai tout fait pour
essayer d'être un méchant dans ce monde
de méchants entre autres j'ai démarré en
naissant le 13 août 1961 et on parle pas
non 13 août 1961 importance est marquant
c'est le début de la construction du mur
de berlin
je vous jure c'est vrai je suis né le 13
août 1961
j'ai essayé d'aider par d'être un vrai
méchant et j'ai continué parce que quand
je suis arrivé au monde je suis arrivé
avec un petit problème de santé je suis
arrivé avec une double cataracte
congénitale doublé d'un design us doublé
d'un strabisme doublé d'un glaucome un
peu lourd quand on est gamin
enfin quand je dis gamin c'est tout
petit j'avais quelques heures on s'en
est pas aperçu tout de suite et puis
quand on est aperçu et bien j'ai été
trimballé de deux cliniques en hôpitaux
depuis le torrent chirurgie surgi en
médecins
mais ça en infirmiers et il fallait
qu'on protège puisque bien entendu
j'étais plutôt mal en voyant je n'y
voyais pas grand chose c'est à dire j'y
voyais pas du tout de l'ailier droit et
j'y voyais très peu de balles gauche pas
facile quand on est gamin et je suis né
dans une famille un peu rita lau niçoise
à la pagnol avec des gens qui
s'expriment peu avec un petit accent
comme ça sympathique sympathique est
vraiment gentil et des vrais gentils et
entre j'avais une maman qui était hyper
protectrices et ma petite maman on avait
trouvé de mieux que de me protéger en le
fabriquant un merveilleux casque en
mousse sur moi si vous imaginez
riverains castan mouche et je partais à
l'école avec parce qu'en fait comme je
ne voyais pas le relief
je me cognais partout pour que je me
connais dans les murs je connais dans
les vitres et ça vous fait rire
maintenant à l'époque ça me faisait
vraiment paris ça me faisait mal ça
m'évitait des bosses et ils m'ont
ophtalmo m'avait fait des super lune est
absolument génial avec des espèces de
verre comme ça et pas tout noir et des
coques sur les côtés je n'explique pas
la gueule de con que j'avais c'était
assez terrible et il est ma maman me
protéger et elle me protégeais tellement
que gta mais j'étais vraiment protéger
des bosses ce n'est pas de si j'étais
aussi protéger des copains qui
protégeait des filles 16e pas de risque
pas de filles pas de copains et et donc
du coup j'ai été affublé dès le départ
quand je dis dès le départ c'était
jusqu'à l'âge de 6-7 ans c'est quand
même un peu lourd à porter surnom de
coco belge était officiellement coco
beloeil c'est super franchement je
l'adorais de quoi garder genre une
rancoeur quand même contre le monde et
continuer de devenir un méchant 13 août
1961 les yeux merde je vais devenir un
méchant jeu je continue puis mon papa
lui on est bien content que j'avais
quand même quelques difficultés se dit
on va le mettre
on va l'endurcir on va on va le mettre
au judo je pourrais le maître au karaté
j'y voyais un peu mieux qu'il ya eu des
opérations je commence à faire du judo
du karaté c'est elle et elle éclate je
me suis mais éclatée 20 ans m'éclatais
parce que j'étais pas franchement
méchant quoi j'étais juste en train de
me marrer avec mes potes pour faire du
judo et du karaté c'était génial mon
père venait ouvert le samedi après midi
tiré sur le tatami et en fait je me
faisais tirer la gueule dans tous les
sens c'était assez terrible et j'ai
essayé pourtant encore une fois de la
dette méchant je n'y arrivais toujours
pas je continue je vais les études
classiques un bac je m'inscris endroit
parce que mon grand père était un
méditerranéen comme [ __ ] chier avait
un petit fils patrick qui lui était
avocat et il voulait un autre petit fils
ce frein qui qu'ils soient juges de paix
alors juge de paix c'était vachement
sympa moi dans juge de paix j'aimais
bien j'aimais bien pu juger mais pas
trop c'est un peu difficile et alors et
le droit je ne supportais quasiment pas
le droit du tout quoi
j'ai fait un an de juge de paix un
endroit et puis j'ai vite arrêté et là
j'ai persévéré en me disant il faut que
je continue d'être méchant j'essaye de
persévérer dans ce monde de brutes
je m'inscris dans une école de commerce
je passe mes concours je rentre dans
l'école de commerce et premier jour
d'école de commerce ailleurs on reçoit
et directeur faire une grand-messe en
disant tout le monde
nous sommes dans un monde de l'eau vous
allez vous battre entre vous et c'était
super c'était super où j'ai fait du
karaté du judo je savais me battre mais
globalement j'avais quand même quelques
petites difficultés mais je me suis
accroché je suis allé au bout du truc
que j'ai eu mon diplôme j'ai été
vachement content et la non content
d'avoir été dans le monde des loups
comme ça pendant quelques années je me
suis dit il faut que je choisisse un
super métier j'avais pris une option
marketing et pub je vais faire de la
publicité parce que c'est un monde de
méchants quoi c'est génial quand elle
veut le monde de méchant on vit dans un
monde de méchants pub je fais de la pub
99 francs en btp pd1 je pense que vous
avez vu le film c'était véritablement ça
des gens vachement sympa type plutôt
superficielle des relations avec nos
clients qui étaient terrifiantes et puis
des patrons je supportais pas je ne
supportais pas d'avoir un mec au dessus
de moi une autorité
j'en fais deux trois comme ça je les eu
je m'amuse et je me dis bon là faut
vraiment que je sois méchant jusqu'au
bout je vais être natron parce que
patron c'est méchant donc je crée mon
agence de pub avec mes copains associés
puis non content de me soucier avec un
copain et créer une agence de pub qu'est
ce que je fais aussi je m'associe à un
groupe franco américain américain
méchant terrifiant je continue je crée
cette agence les trucs marche bien et
puis je me sentais de plus en plus
décalé quand même j'essayais toujours
d'être un méchant dans le monde des
méchants mais profondément avec un adn
de gentils avec je vous disais une
famille italo niçoise qui m'avait plutôt
couvent et qui m'avait plutôt fait
gentil et j'ai essayé de lutter contre
tous et ses réflexes de gentils et et
donc du coup ben je faisais de la pub
j'adorais ça je faisais la créativité de
la stratégie et puis en même temps je
m'occupais beaucoup des gens je m'occupe
de mes collaborateurs un peu avant
l'heure je faisais du travail
collaboratif et mon associé christian
disait mais franck tu nous sors mais
avec mon travail collaboratif là on est
là pour faire des capteurs 3d film télé
franchement ton travail collaboratif sam
bon et puis mais mais mais associé avec
un disait exactement la même chose et et
moi je m'occupais de mes collaborateurs
je le prenais de l'argent du temps et en
argent social on n'est pas là pour faire
du social rétaux merdier je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure pas le père noël tout ça
mais moi j'étais bien je jeu franchement
je me marrais bien ai eu marre et pas
trop et un moment j'ai dit non là je
peux pas je vais arrêter
et là j'ai arrêté j'ai revendu mon
agence de publicité à mes associés mais
j'ai pas revendu comme ça des choses
sont m interroger en fait j'avais
rencontré un certain nombre de personnes
et notamment dans les rencontres qu'en
fait vous savez parfois des rencontres
un peu structurante dans la vie j'avais
rencontré quelqu'un qui m'avait fait
toucher du doigt un courant de pensée
dont vous avez peut-être entendu parler
qui s'appelle le courant de pensée de
l'école de palo alto aux états unis
quoique des méchants finalement aux
états unis plutôt même des gens
vachement bien parfois
et ce courant de pensée de l'école de
palo alto qui était situé précisément à
santa cruz vers san francisco était
composé de femmes et d'hommes formidable
d'aider des humains pour ne pas dire
humaniste avec des gens comme je sais
pas si ça vous parle
virginia s'attirent comme david gordon
comme milton erickson comme gregory
bateson comme carl rogers
et puis entre autres un type qui m'a
marqué que je n'ai pas connu moi même
mais dont les théories notamment une des
théories été formidable un grand
monsieur qui s'appelait paul watzlawick
32 points au scrabble me demandez pas
comment ça c'est fait et elle avait
travaillé sur quelque chose qui me kim
problème est vraiment beaucoup et
notamment qui m'amenait à vérifier que
ce que j'avais vécu finalement dans
toute ma ma vie jusque là était vrai peu
le disait que la relation de confiance
capable de créer et d'entretenir avec
les gens est bien plus importante que le
contenu
concrètement il disait que la relation
de confiance englobe le contenu ce que
moi je je traduisais par la relation
prime sur le contenu
concrètement ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que dans n'importe quel type de
contexte que ce soit un contexte
personnel avec vos enfants vos époux vos
épouses avec votre famille mais aussi
dans des contextes professionnels
si vous n'avez pas cette relation de
confiance votre contenu aussi beau
soit-il ne passe pas et pour planter le
clou j'ai la même que si vous avez de
l'or en barre à offrir aux gens si vous
n'avez pas pris le temps de créer cette
relation de confiance et bien les gens
vont considérer que cette ce contenu
c'est de la merde véritablement et je
pense que vous le tester au quotidien
vous l'avez peut-être encore testé
aujourd'hui oui hier où cette semaine
regardez lorsque vous essayez de
prospecter ou lorsque vous essayez de
faire précéder contexte de changements à
certains de vos collaborateurs et voyez
des difficultés vous pouvez avoir
si vous avez des vraies difficultés que
ça coince vous apercevez souvent alors
ça peut être parfois un problème de
d'organisation du contenu mais assez
rarement très souvent c'est parce qu'il
n'y a pas entre vous et l'autre où les
autres
cette relation de confiance dont je vous
parle et ça c'est essentiel
quand vous êtes confrontés par exemple à
la maladie
vous soignez jamais aussi bien que quand
vous êtes avec un médecin avec lequel
vous êtes en confiance
d'ailleurs une grande partie du chemin
de la guérison est faite parce qu'il ya
cette relation de confiance
lorsque vous êtes rappelez vous quand
vous étiez gamin avec vos parents quand
vous aviez la chance d'avoir des parents
qui étaient proches de vous qui vous
synchronisait qu'il vous prenez là où
vous en étiez et qui était complètement
capable de se rappeler qu'ils avaient
été eux-mêmes des gosses vient
automatiquement il se passait des choses
merveilleuses d'entre vous et notamment
on était capable d'écouter la notion de
contenu et je me suis vraiment intéressé
à tous ces partis là des gens on
apercevoir que j'ai toutes les personnes
qui réussit c'est autour de moi et en
creusant des gens qui étaient beaucoup
plus connu que des gens que j'avais
autour de moi mais qui n'était pas connu
il y avait vraiment des constantes il
constante que vous vous retrouvez chez
des gens comme par exemple commandant
dit on en parlait tout à l'heure david
en parlait des gens comme lâche
valaisanne sous la peau d'âne de
solidarnosc que j'arrivais le ski
rappelez vous plus proche de nous et
plus proche de moi parce que c'était un
voisin
l'abbé pierre rappelez vous alors vous
étiez peut-être tout ce n'est moi non
plus d'ailleurs mais les sorties
diverses 54 et même ça continue jusqu'à
sa mort la manière dont ils étaient
faits dont il fonctionnait nelson
mandela je sais pas si vous avez vu le
film invictus merveilleux film qui
démontre toutes les toutes les capacités
les merveilleux talent cet homme là est
madame karmazin vous paraît même
karmazin après c'était tellement
décalage entre gandhi à damazin enfin
bon je parlais de l'amc ahmad en fait
ces gens là avaient une constante
plusieurs constantes première constante
c'est une véritable capacité et savoir
faire
on en parlait aussi tout à l'heure
françoise en parler merveilleusement
bien à être bienveillant et respectueux
mais bienveillant au vrai sens du terme
ce sont des gens qui sont toujours en
train de défendre des causes mais jamais
contre et toujours pour qu'ils
respectent les gens profondément pour ce
qu'ils sont
ce sont aussi des gens qui sont capables
de comment
moore et d'humilité je mets ces deux
mots ensemble parce qu'ils ont la même
racine étymologique humour et humilité
pas l'humidité
ça vient de l'us de la poussière c'est
se rappeler d'où l'on vient
ce sont des gens qui précisément se
rappeler d'où ils venaient des gens
comme nelson mandela se rappelait
jusqu'à la fin de ses jours d'où il
venait
ce sont des gens qui étaient capables de
gratuité et dodo véritablement le don du
temps le don de même c'est à dire qu'il
n'était pas il ne tombez pas dans le
piège du temps c'est de l'argent à
l'argent oui oui c'est vrai mais c'est
pas aussi important que ça et d'ailleurs
on retourne les choses très souvent
c'était des gens qui étaient capables de
prendre du temps pour en gagner beaucoup
après ce sont aussi des gens qui étaient
totalement capable d'une véritable
honnêteté mais pas l'honnêteté honnêteté
lala l'honnêteté intellectuelle la
congruence c'est à dire que il disait
avec les mots 7%
quelqu'un avait dit tout à l'heure ce
qu'il disait comportement comment
comportement tellement pardon 93% et
donc du coup précisément ce qu'il
pensait il était aligné droits dans
leurs bottes et en même temps je vous
disais gentil mais pas con on peut être
gentils et pas qu'on ait pour être pas
quand il avait deux qualités
exceptionnelles il avait une grande
détermination à aller au bout des
relations difficiles
aller au bout des idées qu'il portait et
souvent les idées qu'il portait était
des idées anti conformiste et puis il
avait aussi cette capacité à poser un
cadre mills et pas n'importe comment ce
cadre il concrets de manière
collaborative un cadre ils le respectent
eux-mêmes il le faisait respecter sans
aucun passe-droit et ces qualités là je
m'apercevais que tous les gens qui
réussissent et dans mais mon contexte
professionnel étaient des gens qui
portaient cette qualité qui vraiment les
vivaient les incarner au quotidien et je
parle de madame karmazin vous la
connaissez pas mais mme karman
je vous en parlais de minutes c'était
une merveilleuse prof vous savez on a
tous des profs on rencontre dans la vie
qui nous marque
je pense que vous n'avez jamais été
aussi bon que quand vous avez une prof
qui avait su créé avec vous une vraie
relation de confiance
rappelez vous c'était peut-être nul à
chier en maths et puis un jour très bon
parce que vous avez une fan qui est
exceptionnel même karmazin c'est une
prof d'histoire géo
je n'ai plus jamais revu je pense
qu'elle est devenue mais elle était
géniale vous savez quand on rentre de
vacances on a la boule au ventre c'est
terrible on va rentrer à l'école on est
passés éventuellement si on a peu de
paul
dans une classe supérieure on arrive le
premier jour et rappelez vous on vous
dit asseyez vous prenez une demi-feuille
celles à deux mille feuilles
justin l'horreur [ __ ] on prend l'avis
feuille alors vous écrivez vos nom
prénom date de naissance profession des
parents qu'est ce qu'on en a à [ __ ] de
la profession départ et puis vous
écrivez votre adresse et votre numéro de
téléphone on sait jamais des fois que je
suis obligée de en vidéo et et
éventuellement vous écrivez le nom le
prénom de votre soeur votre frère pour
savoir si vous étiez dans la lignée d'un
cancre ou d'un bel air et et en europe
mais rigoler mais rappelez vous la suite
moi j'en avais mal au bide
j'étais malade rien que l'idée d'y
penser la deuxième chose qu'on vous
demander de faire c'était prenez une
feuille blanche
tu as tout de suite vous avez rempli
truc vous pensiez que j'étais sorti
d'affaires que dallas interrogations
écrit la première la surprise la
connerie la merde on vous interroge pour
savoir quel est votre niveau dans ladite
matière l'angoissent même karmazin
c'était tout sauf ce hammam karmazin
c'était une prof d'histoire-géo génial
qu'est ce qu'elle faisait même qu'un
nasa elle faisait pas des contes
histoires faisait pas des courses chez
nous elle nous racontait des belles
histoires
elle nous faisait visiter le monde les
trois premières heures qu'on avait passé
avec elle ou serait-ce que c'était trois
heures créativité pure et dure deux
heures pour se présenter elle joue avec
nous et puis une heure pour poser le
cadre de manière collaborative ont
respecté ont signé en bas la charte le
cadre le rituel est ensuite derrière
quand elle nous ait des interrogations
écrites mais contrairement aux autres
profs son seul objectif parce qu'elle
aimait ses élèves
elles émettent est passionné par sa
matière c'était nous faire apprendre
c'était pas de bus contrôler pour nous
plaisait la gueule et oui et donc du
coup qu'est ce qu'elle faisait pour nous
faire apprendre à nous et pas des
interrogations écrites surprise à la con
on était tranquille en histoire journée
30 quand qu'on avait c'est ce domaine
général vous savez pourquoi
d'abord parce qu'elle était bien gaulée
elle sentait bon eh ouais mais elle
était respectueuse bienveillante et tout
ce que je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
et en plus de ça nous donnait des sujets
parce que ce soit seule obsession
c'était qu'on apprenne donc le seul
moyen pour nous d'apprendre on apprenait
par coeur auprès sens du terme parce
qu'on était tellement subjugué par ce
qu'elle nous raconter pendant deux
heures qu'on rentrait le soir on avait
rien à réapprendre
on avait tout appris par coeur au vrai
sens du terme comme nous fait apprendre
dès la citation à la con et du coup à la
vdl s'attirer les foudres des aux
professeurs parce qu'ils comprenaient
pas que 30 cancres qui avaient en
général entre deux et sept domaines
général puisse avoir seize tous
16le mettre le moins bon avait 12 le
meilleur avait 19 ans d'histoire géo
pour de rêve arbaz il rébarbative par
définition un le sous développement en
amont n'en avait rien à [ __ ] le
gouvernement de vichy mais rien à [ __ ]
mais non on est on apprenait c'était
dément c'était démentiel alors voyez
cette force de 20m karmazin j'en parle
parce que c'était vraiment structurant
c'est vraiment quelque chose que vous
avez tous vécu je suis sûr qu'il ya pas
une personne ici qui n'a pas vécu un
prof qui était génial
alors voyez là à chaque fois que vous
avez des choses importantes et
stratégiques
la relation de confiance prime sur le
conte alors maintenant pour finir pour
conclure rappelez vous d'une chose vous
êtes tous des gentils vous pouvez tous
heureux de venir si vous avez un peu
oublié des gentils vous l'êtes à la
maison rappelez vous comment vous dit
merci comment vous congratuler
rappelez vous comment vous remercier
véritablement du fond du coeur en
regardant les gens et en prenant le
temps de discuter avec eux rappelez-vous
la manière dont vous pouvez
effectivement complimenter au sens de
complémenter les gens et pour finir je
voulais vous dire que on a aucun risque
à la rencontre avec les autres auront au
contraire le risque c'est de ne plus
ouvrir aux autres
le risque c'est ne plus ouvrir le coeur
aux autres est ce que je vous suggère
c'est véritablement de de retrouver tout
ça parce que vous verrez vous en
sortirez grandi on fera grandir les
autres et puis je voulais aussi
remercier tous les gens qui sont passés
avant moi qui vont passer après parce
que franchement ce que vous dites c'est
top moi je me régale et puis je voulais
remercier ma petite sophie c'est ma
petite campagne vous la connaissez pas
elles sont bons elle est belle
parce qu'elle avait des théâtres cacher
aujourd'hui à la complicité vachement
important pour moi qu'elle soit là merci